walk out this video peristeri are never
played this guy from Germany does not
does he have a name in there nope it was
very short on in but no name oh it's a
brand new account okay so let's see what
do we get here kind of a symmetrical
English this this I saw recently and
known this game even shook vaghela graph
and keep brought down night be three
Queen a5h three is what you want your
plate d 6 g 4 and the PSAC it's quite
quite funny the interesting is also has
c5 in this position takes and rub the
eight this is some recently become
fashionable don't ask me how exactly
this is played I am this exact yeah like
this this guy actually knows the theory
do you play Bishop g4 here or not hmm
don't really I don't know if I should do
a trade Quincy hmm
all right come on don't know and I don't
know so we have a position where the
pawn structure is completely symmetrical
almost completely symmetrical C&D pawns
are missing what difference is that i
have this open diagonal and the am i
wonder if i can take here or should take
him okay come on let's do that i'm not
really sure about the move but i'd like
to have some some some imbalance in this
position to not make it come in so
easily to not allow white such an easy
play I came to take Bishop g4 yes always
kept okay probably i need to do that
anyway and now 95 is of course a problem
hmm yeah going all the way back looks
very iffy but 95 is coming all the time
okay this experiment with taking on c3
will probably stay exactly that an
experiment to be to be done once and
only once that's interesting they can
just take it off I mean I was thinking
about this idea with e 5 but he has no
mate I mean where's the maid Bishop 6
you know
yeah he just had some hallucination I
guess it had a very good position Bishop
takes you three was really a really
really nonsense idea this was very good
for white
gets them still a bit tangled up here
need a bit of a bit of slight precision
at least is six probably first
stabilized a bit and then knight c6 or
maybe nights you form to this also night
c4 and then night night d to be six
maybe
I don't want to allow any stuff him I
have the time to do that this precaution
this caution moves what's what I need
still need to be aware of with some
Bishop to e7 to f6 this would still be
still be a very dangerous attack yeah
this needs to be prevented
okay get this back into play yeah maybe
just okay if I go Knight b6 sound he has
Bishop c5 well that's not really a
threat it's not really threat I can
really play just Knight b6 and Bishop d7
it's really not much you can do about it
Bishop c5 Bishop e7 Bishop fhe checking
Jade and no check white resigns yeah
this was a lucky win really 95 was just
an hallucination yeah taking 1c3 was
really bad idea I mean really not really
not i don't i don't think i should
repeat that and not not clear what what
I should do really it looks a bit better
for white anyway this position there's
always this kind of stuff going on
here's some the night oops it's just
more active right here don't know jack
sure
I can probably just just play play slow
museum and improve slowly h3 f 4 for
example something like that or just
night deforms also not bad intending
night b-52 c7 I probably now okay maybe
Bishop d7 yeah it's not it's not a great
position really the computer wants to
play Bishop f1 maybe it's one point
Bishop b5 yeah it's a it's a very
uncomfortable position very
uncomfortable I would like to play h3
and f4 f4 f5 this would be excellent if
white managers that therefore
immediately there's Bishop g4 again so
this is Maya play age three yeah this is
just excellent form for white just a
great position yeah I don't know this
line has recently be coming to become
fashionable but I don't really know how
it is played I think this is really a
known position but maybe something to
LCM or take and not not have six I don't
know okay thanks for watching